bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du nouveau téléphone de wei wei le wei
wei nos valeurs la gamme nova chinois
yang wei est assez récent elle est
arrivée il n'y a pas très longtemps et
déjà on arrive sur le nouveau modèle le
nova 2 c'est un téléphone qui ne coûte
pas très cher qu'on peut comparer en
termes de prix si vous voulez à honor 8
un téléphone qui coûtent moins de 400
euros et qui pourtant a plein de très
bonnes fonctionnalités double capteur
arrière une excellente caméra de ciel
fillon 20 mégapixels la possibilité
d'exporter ses photos au format raw
enfin plein de choses plein de petits
détails qui fait que ce téléphone est
très sexy malgré son petit prix je vous
emmène tout de suite avec moi à berlin
pour aller voir ensemble le huawei nova
2 c'est parti
aujourd'hui on va parler du nouveau
smartphone de well well well nova de
smartphones qui est plutôt cool qui
tient bien dans la main et qui a plein
de fonctionnalités hyper sexy surtout en
termes de photos c'est un appareil qui a
une caméra celle fit enfin mégapixels
qui vous permet effectivement lorsque
vous allez prendre des photos voix
lorsque vous avez filmé pour vous voir
en mode self y d'avoir une super qualité
et ça c'est vraiment bien
niveau de caméra arrière vous avez une
douzième xl et une 8 mégapixels bien
évidemment le flash arrière ici vous
avez votre capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour déverrouiller facilement
votre téléphone niveau la caméra vous
pouvez déjà exporté vos photos en gros
c'est extrêmement pratique lorsque vous
travaillez sous photoshop que vous
voulez vraiment travailler dans la
meilleure qualité
ça c'est juste stocks pour les
professionnels et vous pouvez aussi
faire des photos en 3d pour faire une
photo en 3d vous allez prendre votre
appareil vous allez viens pas c'est un
objet et lui il va le modéliser comme
dans matrix par exemple
pouvoir reconnaître les différentes
cours les différentes formes et ensuite
vous les déplacez directement sur votre
téléphone et ça c'est vraiment très
pratique et très simple un smartphone
sur lequel vous pouvez faire aussi du
split screen ce qui est vraiment très
pratique aujourd'hui vous allez mettre
votre application fario et une autre
application sous ce qui fait que vous
avez toujours un oeil sur quelque chose
d'important dans trois ans remake ou
naviguer au dessus et ça c'est vraiment
très très pratique vous avez 4 gigabits
de ram et 64 giga de stockage à terre ou
dans ce téléphone un chargement rapide
et en termes de job mais sur branchez
votre prise jack ça pour moi c'est très
intéressant parce que lorsque vous
voulez filmé par exemple pour avoir une
application pour voulu filmer une scène
vous branchez votre petit micro robes de
suivre et vous avez une qualité sans
qu'il est bien meilleur qu'avec les
micros intégrés
côté processeur c'est un kir insu 159
rock d'accord vous avez à l'intérieur un
androïde 7.0 avec une surcouche emotion
85.1 l'été patrice est une de 1950
milliampères heures qui devrait faire le
job
surtout côté écran vous avez un écran 5
pouces être hd en 1920 par 1080
ce qui est vraiment très sensible ce
téléphone c'est lorsque vous avez fait
une photo vous pouvez rajouter un aspect
un petit peu plus fondu à côté pleurs
qui très sympa sur vos photos vous
pouvez lire toucher à mon avis ce
téléphone il est déjà très pratique très
sympa en termes d'écrans il fonctionne
bien le prix pour 399 euros il n'est pas
très cher mais le côté très sympa
l' avantage de téléphone c'est la
photographie la modélisation en trois
dimensions c'est sympa d'avoir un
capteur selphy en 20 méga pixels ce qui
à mon avis est très sympa dites moi ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous avez déjà
eu tout un téléphone way we know est-ce
que vous envisageriez en avoir entre le
prix ça peut être intéressant
la demo tu sois commentaires et on en
parle très vite et pas moi je remercie
je vous dis à très bientôt
salut
[Musique]